the government says everyone who returns
from Syria must expect to be
investigated by the police to determine
whether they've committed a criminal
offense and whether they pose a threat
to national security
but lawyers of the family of the girls
who went from Bethnal Green point out
that the time they departed Police
Commissioner Bernhard Hogan Howe said
that they would be treated as victims as
long as they hadn't committed any
further offenses while in Syria however
it is an offense to join is because it's
a proscribed
terrorist group in her interview Shamima
Begum doesn't portray herself as a
victim she admits being a willing eius
bride and this helps the prosecution now
the home office says nine hundred
individuals have traveled to Syria
anti-terrorist police say there are
around 200 of them at large who would
pose a threat if they returned to the UK
of the 900 180 have been killed in the
battlefield including Shamima Begum's
friend at Cadiz a Sultana but 360
individuals have returned to the UK of
those many are now considered no longer
a secure earth national security concern
the home office says there have been 40
prosecutions and these are four of them
at arena shaquille mohamed ahmed yusuf
Sawa those two from Birmingham were
convicted with the help of those
photographs showing them carrying the
guns and Mohammed Abdullah who was
convicted thanks to Sky News his is
files collected from the Syrian border
now today we asked should the pregnant
British schoolgirl who joined is be
allowed to return to the UK 16 percent
said yes
no said 76 percent so 88 percent said
they didn't know however she does retain
her British citizenship so she is
allowed to return perhaps against the
wishes of public opinion but being so
high-profile I would expect authorities
to investigate her very carefully